So, if President Trump looks
happy today, it's not because
Putin finally accepted
his Facebook friend request.
-(laughter) -It's because
his two favorite things--
Twitter and live TV--
are merging.
-(imitates explosions)
-(audience sighing and gasping)
I don't know why the
Twitter bird always just looks
like someone put a finger
up its ass.
(laughter)
-Tweet, tweet.
-(laughter)
Twitter just announced
that it plans to stream live TV
24 hours a day, guys.
Because they...
Oh, you don't seem...?
(laughter)
Their reaction was like,
"Oh, so why would they do that?"
-(laughter)
-They want to be 100% sure
that they occupy all
of your attention while pooping.
I don't know
why they're doing it it.
-(laughter)
-Twitter CEO said their goal is
to become something
always if the background
of people's daily lives,
like CNBC in airports, or...
or maybe wondering
if Carla was the one for you,
and maybe you made
the biggest mistake of your life
this whole time
getting on that plane.
I mean, sure, you love Barbara,
and you've been
through a lot of stuff together,
but she isn't about passion.
It's all about maintenance
at this point,
and you have needs, too!
What about your needs?!
-Anyway...
-HENRY ZEBROWSKI: Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah. Get on that plane.
HARDWICK:
So...
why don't...?
So, Twitter is making a big
gamble with this content shift
by assuming that their audience
has the attention span
to follow anything longer
than a hashtag,
"Brave picture
of Demi Lovato's face."
-(laughter)
-So, comedians,
what's one of the shows
that we might see on Twitter TV?
-Henry. -The Real Dank Memes
of Tallahassee.
-HARDWICK: Points.
-(laughter, applause)
Ophira.
Say Yes to the Bless.
-Yes, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Maria Bamford.
-NCIS: Twitter,
144 characters per episode.